and I can port that through the
government's ongoing monitoring and
testing program as of today they have
now been 818 thousand five hundred and
thirty nine tests for the virus across
the UK including fifty-two thousand four
hundred and twenty nine tests that took
place yesterday one hundred and sixty
five thousand two hundred and twenty one
people have tested positive and that's
an increase of four thousand seventy six
cases on yesterday's number now as the
health secretary announced yesterday
from today we're moving to an improved
daily reporting system for deaths so
that deaths in all settings are included
wherever the individual has tested
positive for code 19 rather than just
those in hospitals and those figures
show that up to yesterday on the new
measure we have recorded an additional
three thousand eight hundred and eleven
deaths in total and I think it's just
important to say that those additional
deaths were spread over the period from
the second of March for the 28th of
April so they they don't represent a
sudden surge in the number of deaths
sadly today's figures show an additional
765 deaths compared to yesterday I'll
let professor Doyle talk us through the
data in detail in a little while but I
think we must never lose sight of the
fact that behind every statistic there
are many human lives that have been
tragically lost before their time